let's uh
recapture everyone so uh
once again uh luca travis line
all right so
we we now got to the point of having
defined what is a computational problem
from the point of view of average case
complexity and what are various ways of
defining what it means for an algorithm
to efficiently solve such a
computational problem
uh and now towards the goal of uh
replicating as much as possible of what
we know how to do for a worse case
complexity
i would like to describe how you reduce
one column to another so
how you um
listening backwards
how you can
start from one problem for which you
have
reason to believe or conjecture that
it's
intractable it's hard it doesn't have
efficient algorithms as we just defined
and how to then show that some other
problem also is intractable and doesn't
have algorithms of this type
now let's maybe think about uh
decision problems like problems that
have a
yes or no answer as a
complete example although definition
reduction also applies to other kind of
problems
so let's say we have two
problems some problem p with some
distribution d over inputs
some volume p prime with some
distribution d prime
now if there wasn't a distribution in
the middle
then a reduction
would be some
polynomial time computable
transformation function
uh f
that maps
inputs of column p two inputs and
current p prime
such that the correct answer stays the
same
such that
this is a correct answer for
an input x x of p
is deducible in the case of decision
problems let's say it's the same
as the
correct answer
for
f of x
as an input of b prime
so then
the way you would convert an algorithm
of p prime into an algorithm for p would
be
a given input compute f
uh treat f of x as an input to p prime
you have an algorithm for it
solve it and then get back the answer
so that's how it works for
world case complexity
now the issue with
distribution problems
is that
if you apply this type of transformation
then
you might take a typical input for
problem p
and then obtain a highly uh
structured and unlikely input for
problem p prime
now what we know about the algorithm for
p prime is that it's
typically efficient but there will be
so
several inputs on which it's not
efficient at all
or
according to other possible definitions
there might be
a large subclasses or inputs on which
it's incorrect
and now if
this transformation is not carefully
crafted what could happen is that
basically all the possible inputs for p
get transformed into
so very specific types of inputs for p
run which happen to be all the inputs on
which the p prime algorithm fails
so what's
missing for the definition to work out
is something that tells us that if we
take
a high probability mass inputs for p and
we apply f
we should overall get a
high probability mass
so set of
possible maps
now the way levin defines it
it's again kind of
[Music]
something open to criticism and we will
see some of the issues that come up
so let's look at levi's definition of
reduction
so it's a
it's a function of as before
so it's reduction in the standard size
such that
i guess i will make a
i guess i'll make an assumption that
simplifies the definition a bit although
it's possible to
make a definition work also without this
assumption
so
because remember we were talking about
having a so different distributions for
inputs of
uh
different lengths maybe you're talking
about graphs so there's a distribution
for graphs of size and for every n
so i will
think about fs
mapping
so inputs
in the
support
of
the sub n
so these are inputs
of p
to inputs in the support
of d prime for some other length l
so maybe if it's reduction from graphs
to graphs it will map graphs of size n
to graphs so some other sides but always
the same size it will not
sort of sometimes produce bigger graphs
and sometimes produce smaller graphs
it's also possible to make the
definition work if the outputs of the
reduction has
a variable length it's uh so just that's
technicalities that maybe obscure what
is going on
okay so that's an
unnecessary but simplifying assumption
and
so the interesting property
will be so this idea that
you have to map
high probability mass substitutive
inputs to high probability mass uh
subset of inputs
and levin chose to give this definition
actually
input wise as opposed to talking about
sets
um so it will
say such that
for
every
why
in the
support of the target distribution
the probability
of
getting y
through the reduction
is at most
polynomially larger so
then
the probability of y in the target
distribution
so maybe perhaps before
discussing this definition let's think
of what would be the
gold standard of
reductions the preservative average case
through
the ideal thing would be that f works in
such a way
that
if i
that um
if i pick a random x
according to my
distribution d
and then apply f to it
then
this induced distribution of
values f of x is precisely the
distribution d prime
because then my reduction would be
mapping
a random input of p according to
distribution d into a random input of p
prime with distribution d prime
so then it's clear that whatever works
on p prime
and the prime will also work on p
because i'm literally creating the same
distribution
but
so that would be a
great definition it's just that getting
reductions that works like this it's
almost always impossible
to sort of precisely match
the
target distribution but it's also too
much to ask for
basically all that you're really
asking is that
if the prime is some low probability
mass
set of
bad inputs you don't just keep hitting
them
with your distribution of
f of x
so
a sort of bad inputs that have low
probability according to d prime should
also have low probability according to f
of x for a random x
so that's what the
living definition is um
aiming for
let's just say that um
if you have some kind of problematic
inputs
for
your algorithm for p prime they will be
generated as f of x for random x we
probably know more than a polynomial
times
the probability that they would have
been generated by
uh deep line
now this definition you could sort of
see that certainly satisfy essentially
preserves the differential tractability
that
some suggested like if there's some
algorithm that
is correct except on a negligibly small
fraction of inputs negligibly small
means that
the probability mass
decreases faster than any inverse
polynomial like
decreases at least like one over n to
the log n or more
well then
uh whatever is a problematic input
for your algorithm for p
to distribution d prime
uh
but sort of any time your f of x is one
of those inputs you are failing in the
reduction
but the probability of this will be at
most
in n times a negligible function which
is still an equilibrium function
but then it's also preserved by levin's
definition and the impliazo's definition
because there
so if you take the point of view of the
algorithm with two inputs one is the
true input one is the accuracy parameter
then in the reduction you just have to
scale your accuracy parameter by
whatever is this
polynomial
and you still get a pull on the running
time
and now
a criticism well
perhaps one
issue with this definition is that
this function knife itself
is always right
in a sense that
it always must
compute some f of x for which the
correct answer is the same as the
correct answer for x
but actually it will be fine if the
reduction itself
fails sometimes
like maybe it maps to some other input
for which the correct answer is
different probably this doesn't happen
too often
also we're asking the functionals to run
in polynomial time but actually it would
be okay
if it ran in uh
expected personal time or
if it was efficient according to the
definitions that we
gave before
it will also be
okay
so another point it's
requiring
this
kind of property
for
every possible
string in the support of the
distribution d prime
while
maybe something that talks more about
perhaps subset of
inputs might be
easier to achieve
but the thing is actually
even
with
possibly any of
these
generalizations or weakenings of the
definition that one could introduce
it's actually extremely difficult to get
any
reduction to work
i will tell you in a minute that
reduction networks is something actually
extremely interesting with data
compression
but
um somehow if you think about any of
the problems that are being talked about
in the other lectures of the boot camp
and
sort of the
objective of
this program
reductions among them are extremely
difficult and so mostly unknown
like i don't know take the
random force that in random trees up
can you
reduce the problem of certifying
unsatisfied video random forces
to the problem of certifying random
unsatisfiability of run
answer is a video random threesome
and
it's not clear how you
get started about thinking that you can
certainly do threesat to force up but
not the other way
or
planting click with different click size
i mean clearly the bigger is the country
click the easier is the problem
but
um if you have some algorithm that finds
clicks plenty clicks of size
i don't know
20 logan
is it clear it implies that you can find
plenty clicks of size 30 logan because
those are totally different
distributions of graphs
and some if i give you a graph with a
planty clique of size 20 logan
can you get one that has a planted
little size 30 logan can you do it with
only a polynomial domination
like you see here
i mean it's
it's not clear so the
um
lot of problems are trivially reducible
to one another from the point of view of
worst case complexity
are kind of
[Music]
uh tricky here
before click you can do it like you'll
no actually i'm not sure
i mean i didn't think too too much
before making those examples but
if you pretty much
think about
any two problems that you're interested
in from the point of view of
coverage case analysis
or even one troll that you're interested
in but you change one parameter
it's very unlikely that you can that you
can construct reduction uh between them
so in fact that's
the main bad news about this world
theory
that
kind of when it works it says very
interesting things
but
it almost never works like it's
extremely difficult to
construct
reductions according to any
reasonable definitions the few
reductions that we know satisfy the
definition is written here
all right so now i want to
um
sorry
all right now i want to work with this
definition and
come up with a
complete problem
for uh
np like i want to come up with one
particular problem
and
something that is a reasonable to call
the uniform distribution of inputs
and
i will show that
any wooden average algorithm according
to any of the definitions we talked
about for this one problem
implies good and average algorithms for
all problems in p
not under all distributions but under a
lot of
distributions
right so for now we will
think about
when i say lots of distributions
we'll talk about what are called
what levine called the
polynomially computable distributions
which are the distributions where
given a y
we can compute
in polynomial time
the cumulative probability of y
where this is some total ordering maybe
it's the excitographic order
okay so we'll call
a distribution of inputs polynomially
computable
if you can compute in polynomial time
the
cumulative distribution functions for
inputs of a certain light like given
some input tell me what is the
probability of getting one that is like
zero graphically smaller
and then we will see how to
sort of handle more general classes of
distributions for now we will
talk about this
and we will deal with the following
problem
a canonical np complete problem
called
bonded halting
not a very natural one but it's sort of
a starting point
so in this form in input
it's a
non-deterministic turing machine
an input x
and
a number integer
t
and the question is
does m accept
x in time at most
so this is a problem that we can prove
in a minute that is np
in the standard sense
we will sort of
through the next half hour that it's
also
complete in an average case sense
and so and
so this will
tie together
a lot of the loose ends that we've
accumulated so far
so first let's see
that this problem is
um
mp completed in the standard sense
according to
[Music]
so worst case complexity
so take any
np problem
uh i don't know a
so that means that a
is
decided
by a non-deterministic turing machine
ma
in polynomial
time so a reduction from
a to this bonded halting problem
it's that given input x for a
we can
construct the input
an input like this
so this is a
a possible input for the bonding halting
problem
and
the question does ma accept x in time at
most
t
is precisely the question
is x a yes input for a
and certainly from
this triple can be constructed from x
immediately just by writing down the
code for the turing machine copying x
and then
right now this polynomial bond
there's only one issue about this
problem is that this number t
if you just write it out in binary
the number of bits it takes is
log t so you can actually physically
write
an exponentially big number
and so um
someone now this problem is not even in
np anymore because we are talking about
an exponential time non-deterministic
machine
so this number t
needs to be written down in some way so
that
the space that it takes as part of the
input it's proportional to t itself
so we will assume that this is written
in unary
i don't know if what i'm saying makes
sense for
everybody maybe the room
after people are bored after people are
not sure what i'm saying so
written in newark just means that we're
going to write a number in some very
expensive way just so that we don't get
some strange relation between the size
of the input and the numerical value of
the numbers involved so writing a number
in unity just means writing one symbol
for uh
like if you want to write the number 25
in unity you just write 25 symbols
writing in unity just means writing as
many ones as number that you're
representing
and so
abundant whole thing it's kind of
canonical probably np because it's just
saying well
uh execute any non-domestic machine in
any time that you're telling me on
any input that you want so
pretty much the definition any problem
in np can be mapped to
instances of this problem
now the issue is that if you
are now thinking of
a reduction from problem a and some
distribution d of inputs and you want to
map it to bh
under the uniform distribution
well now
um
reduction like this is not working
because maybe the distribution d
is giving very high probability mass
to
small number of possible axes
but
under the uniform distribution those
axis will actually very small
probability
so we are not
preserving the
distributions
so what i'm going to
explain
next is how to get a reduction like this
actually to
[Music]
do work
i also need to explain a bit more
accurately what i mean by the
uniform distribution for the bonnie
halting problems
but
i'll perhaps
do that later
so here is levin's idea that's really
the biggest idea idea in
in the paper it's to say to reduce an
input x
to the bonding halting problem
i'll do something like this i'll
i'll compute
a
compressed representation of x
some kind of injective compression
m prime
will first decompress
x from
c x
and then it will simulate
m a on x
so just as before the effect that we are
achieving is to simulate m a on x so the
reduction is correct
and then t will be chosen so that it's
enough time
to do
the decompression
plus the simulation of ma
and so then
the idea here
it's that
we want to create
an input for the button helping problem
that is a as close to being uniformly
distributed as possible
but what we are starting from it's an x
that is coming from a
definitely well from a distribution that
we know but
it become very complicated is certainly
far from possibly far from
but
if we optimally compress x
what does
an optimal compression of x look like
for a random x
well it's going to look essentially like
a
random string of bits
yes of
lesson one of the intuitions from
shannon's theory that
when you compress a
non-uniform distribution
what you obtain
is kind of uniform because if there was
still
some bias in the visibility from the
compression
there would still be some kind of
missing entropy and you could still
compress some more
uh
and so now if you look at the output of
this reduction well
m prime is just
a fixed machine
just some code that is there and it's
always the same
it's not a random string of bits
but we're really kind of comparing a
constant size string of bits to a random
string of bits
so the
kind of ratio between this probability
which is really what we are talking
about it's only a constant so that's
fine
so then we have
c of x for random x
and if it's
optimally compressed
that's also kind of like a random
strength
and then we have all
kind of a string of symbols but there is
also a string of symbols in the
distribution that we have in mind
and so
i mean i'm literally waving my hands but
uh we will see calculations for uh all
of this
wait well t is actually all once or t is
you choose to be a string of random
symbols but you only care about its
length when you do metabolism
um mood work if we want the reduction to
be deterministic
we should think of t as being a sequence
of uh all ones
okay otherwise it doesn't work if we
allow probabilistic reductions then we
could think of t as being just some
arbitrary sequence of symbols
and the number t is represented as the
length of that sequence
but but then within that part of the if
i do a deterministic production
then that part of the
string m prime c of x t doesn't really
look at all like a random string and t
might like because you have to write t
in unity this actually might be a very
long part of the string
yes but uh so that that's where the uh
notion of what it means for something to
be a random instance of uh the bonding
health uh come from
so it
if you allow t to
because we're so centi is in unary so
exactly what does it mean to have a
random instance of this problem where a
big chunk of it is supposed to be
all ones
so certainly one thing we could do is to
say
t is a arbitrary sequence of symbols
it's represented by its length
and
what we will do
is to
actually what living does as well
instead of to
cheat a bit answer the notion of what it
means for something to be a random
instance of uh
bonded halting also we'll define it what
it means for something to be a random
instance of one adult in the following
way
so this is sort of
it's going to be a uniform pony adulting
instance
of length n
so first
we choose a random number from one to
one
then we put
all ones to the right of that
and then we put the random bits to the
left
so this way we will not have to deal
with
randomized reductions but otherwise we
could do what
suggested
okay
and also for things to really work out
what
we sort of have to the left of these all
ones which is a turing machine and some
input
so here i'm kind of
putting these commas but
if you have strings of zeros and ones
you
cannot have commas
so what i appropriately formatted
instance of bundle halting would look
like is that there is a prefix free
representation of the machine m
then there is a prefix free
representation of the string x and then
there are uh cool ones
and if
so
things fail to be in the correct prefix
representation we just think of
m as being some fixed machine it always
rejects and so the default thing it's a
it's a known input
this is just a series of conventions to
say exactly how
things are but
other possible conventions would work
because the key idea is the data
compression part
all right so uh how are we going to
uh x so this is sort of the
idea take an axe and map it into a
invertible
optimally compressed representation of x
and then have
the machine part of the instance of
bonus helping be a machine that will
decompress x
and then
simulate whatever is the non-domestic
algorithm for
problem a
so that takes us to
exactly what kind of compression we are
going to use and
how will the
definitions be satisfied
so we will use what is called the
arithmetic compression
or is my coding
which
will work because we
have made this assumption about
the distribution
on
our
initial problem
to have a polynomial time computable
cumulative distribution
so um as many coding works in the in the
following way
so we have this distribution uh dn
uh
now let's uh
so this is distribution over let's say
binary strings of length and
whatever objects of size and we are
talking about let's just think about
binary strings
so let's as a mental experiment
let's enumerate
the
support of uh
diane
so let's think of it maybe just as being
all binary strings
in lexiographic order
and then here we write the cumulative
probability
all right let's call it
0x so some string packs and here
i have it's cumulative for bdx
so maybe this has a very small one
and then the next one has a slightly
higher one
so the idea of
arithmetic coding
would be to
encode
each string acts in the support of the n
by
its cumulative probability
that's certainly uh so that's a first
approximation
that's because
so let's
that's because it's an injective mapping
if i tell you the cumulative probability
of a string
i am
well let's
start talking about the support of x so
kind of all strings have some
non-zero probability
so if i
tell you the cumulative probability of a
string it uniquely identifies it
because every other one you know all the
preceding ones in lexiographic order
will have a smaller cumulative
probability all the subsequent ones in x
graphic or they would have a bigger one
also
it's an efficiently invertible encoding
because i can do banana research
to find the strain
that has a certain cumulative
probability
okay if i
see a string that has a bigger
probability
than the one that i'm looking for i know
that the one that i'm looking for
comes before in lexiographic order
and
if the one of them look
that i'm looking at as a smaller human
probably the one i'm looking for
comes after in lexiographic order
so i can do
banana research kind of starting from
zero one one one one this thing in the
middle
and then progressively reduce my range
of search by a half it takes n steps to
find the right string
okay now the thing is those humanity
distributions might be
actually
huge numbers to
write down
meaning with lots of decimal digits
and there would be no
no compression
so the
idea of arithmetic coding is to encode x
uh using
enough digits
of clx
to
distinguish it
from
the
predecessor
of x in the election graphic order
and now actually let's think of these
properties as being written down in
binary
so maybe x
looks something like this
but the string before x
i don't know the predecessor of x
maybe it
looks like this
so the
encoding of x according to arithmetic
coding
would be
this binary string
because it's
so enough digits
to
distinguish x from
the string that comes
before x in the lexicography chord
if the
if the successor of x
looks
something like this
then
this will be the encoding of the
successor of x
so with this truncated encoding we can
still do binary search instead of
thinking about there being all zeros
after the translating coin
we still have
increasing numbers
and uh
we can still do
binary search
so what is the
point now of
this encoding
it's that
the number of
bits that it takes to and codex
depends on how much precision i need
to distinguish the cumulative
probability of x from the cumulative
probability of the predecessor of x
so it's a number of digits that depends
really on what is the difference
between the current probability of x and
the cumulative probability of the
processor of x
but this difference is just the
probability of x itself
so
the number of digits
and they are used to encode x
at most actually they are essentially
the same
as something like
[Music]
the soup of the logarithm to base two of
one over
the probability of x
maybe plus one but
i don't think you need plus one but uh
just to be on the same side
and
so you get it right you um
i'm encoding a
string
by its cumulative probability
distribution using enough digits to
distinguish it from its predecessor
which means i keep going until i see a
digit where
my x and its predecessor differ
and
if i keep going for lots of digits it
means that the difference between those
properties is very small
and
and so the probability of
x
is
at most
2 to the minus the number of digits that
i'm using
so the number of digits is at most minus
log of the probability of x
variance is nodding yeah
huh the audience is nothing great i
don't need to keep going
thank you
and now
this is actually optimal
in the sense that um no if you take a
random max
what will be the typical length of the
encoding well
what would be the expected length of the
encoding
well it would be the expectation
uh
according to period of x of
log of 1 over the probability of x
that's the entropy of the distribution
so kind of up to plus one or plus two uh
whatever is right
i am
achieving
an expected length in my encoding which
is the entropy of the distribution i
literally cannot do any better so that's
a
particularly good
encoding strategy
but now let's see how
it's so now
so let's see what's uh
the implication for this
maybe this is a minor technical uh
issue but if the support of dn is not
the entire
set of strings and you cannot really
distinguish x from the predecessor so
you have to go around it somehow and
it's not a big deal or
no it is uh
i mean
this argument also assumes that you have
an effective enumeration of the support
of
the ion okay
and that's um
i think that's okay for a lot of
distributions but
it can be a tricky condition to
adding to the mix that's true
all right now let's
[Music]
see what we've got
we
well
in the way 11
that put that is that you always assume
that inputs come as string of bits so
that there is some encoding of the
objects that we're talking about into
single bits
and
instead of i think instead of
restricting to
just the support like the elements with
positive probability
he allows
it so thinks about encoding arbitrary
strings including probability in zero
strings
so then is encoding will be something
like
code zero followed by what i just
described is the string as positive
probability
or one followed by the string itself
if it has
probability zero or even like less than
one in two to them
so
i think this gets around
this issue
because
for count zero probability or locality
strings you just have the string itself
as part of the encoding
for the others they have positive
probability so the
binary search is well defined
but
yeah you have to
take care of
this issue one way or another
right so now let's say that
with all these species we have our
domination condition
so our reduction starts from x
and produces
machine m prime
c of x now c of x is this arithmetic
coding of x
and a sufficiently large
runtime
and actually
to make sure that we always construct
outputs of
the same length
you know this will be some
polynomial
fixed polynomial in the
length of x
it will sort of be an upward bound so
that
we are sure we can fit m prime the
encoding of x and the running time
if there is extra space we'll just make
t bigger to
fill up the space
because that doesn't
if you overestimate t you don't change
the correctness of the reduction
all right so what does the
analysis of the reduction involve
we have to say that for every
possible output of the reduction
so for every
kind of object that looks like this
the probability
so now this this mapping is actually
injected by the way we constructed it
so
there is only one x that can generate
this y
and so we can just say the copy
according to
x
okay let's try this way that the
probability of
x
needs to be smaller
than some fixed polynomial
times
maybe we'll call u for uniform this
distribution of bonded halting instances
that you have constructed
of land and away
so this is uh what we need to
make sure it's true
okay so
so let's figure out what is the
probability according to this uniform
distribution of
y
well first of all
the breaking point between t and the
rest had to be there
but the breaking point was chosen
uniformly
so that's one over n
so then
the bits of m prime
you know are what they are
always
when you generate according to x
but
in a distribution in a uniform
distribution there are random bits so
the probability that they're really like
this it's
1 over 2
to the
length of m prime
and then there is the probability that
the bits of c of x are like this
and this is one over two to the length
of c of x
but the length of c of x it's uh
it's this it's the logarithm of the
probability of x
so one over 2 to that it's just
it's just the probability of x
and then there is some
[Music]
you know there was this plus one
and here it's one over two that so
that there is maybe an extra constant
and definitely it's a
well it's a data one
so it's bigger than one over poly n
times d of x
which is what we want
and actually i
cheated a little bit here in that
this c of x needs to be written in a
prefix free
prefix free way
the way i described encoding is not
prefix free this can be fixed by adding
an extra login bits
to sort of specify the length of c of x
when we take 1 over 2 to the length of c
of x we will pay an extra polynomial
cost
but that's already
accounted for here
but that's the
so apart from all the technicalities
that's sort of the big idea to compress
the data once you compress your data
optimally you get a random string and
now you're good
okay now in the
remaining two minutes i want to
just point out
some
issues with
this reduction and we sort of see that
they are actually
tomorrow when we talk about it some more
actual issues that we haven't overcome
in the past
37 years
so one issue
it's this
one over two to the length of uh
so we have
so we are comparing the string we are
constructing constructing to a truly
random string
since we are fixing the description of
the algorithm that solves our initial
problem as part of the string
so each bit that we are fixing
it's half in
so it's a factor of two in the ratio
between
probabilities that we are creating and
the target distribution
so overall we lose something that is
exponential
in
the rental problem
we're saying that that's a constant it
doesn't grow with the input
but
this is something that is
exponential in the
length of the code essentially that
describes how
problem a is solved
and
read this ratio in probabilities they
translate in running time
because when we
talked about how we define efficiency we
said well we're assuming that to deal
with the
problematic inputs of smaller smaller
mass maybe you'll take more and more
time with some polynomial
tradeoff so that means that if you
are
kind of changing probabilities by total
decay potentially that translates into
two decay more time in your algorithm
so here you're doing something that is
exponential
in the number of lines of code of your
way of solving a
and
you know even 2 to the 30
it's the limit of feasibility
to do the 100 is completely invisible
how many programs we can write in 40
bits not 40 lines of code but like
40 bits it's
almost nothing
so
if
this exponential dependence on
the code of some program that you are in
mind
is actually a big issue this issue that
arises in a lot of
universal results about average case
complexity including
the existence of
universal one-way functions that maybe
we'll
mention next time
and that appears to be
unavoidable at this level of generality
like if you want to really map problems
into the other and you don't know
anything about your initial problem
problem except the description of how
you would solve it
if you are non-deterministic machines
uh so basic description how you verify
the validity of solutions
these reductions lose something is
exponential in the
number of bits of the code that
describes how you verify solutions so
that's mostly
infeasible
another little point is that
in these reductions you really have to
sort of
you are fixing in the instance that you
construct
something that describes how you
solve your problem your
initial problem
now if
the primary reducing tool like bonding
halting
allows you to kind of describe
programs like turing machines as part of
your instance
at least this part will be constant
even though this is already problematic
but
for many other problems like treesat
click and son
we really don't know how to encode
programs as kind of constant size pieces
of your input
we know how to encode circuits as
polynomial size pieces of your input
but those will be polynomial in the size
of the circuit so in the running time of
the computation that you want to
simulate
but we don't really know how to encode a
program into a constant size piece of
your instance
and this is the biggest limitation of
this theory right the only problems that
have been proved complete in this way
are problems where there is some way to
take a constant size piece of your input
and
let it encode
a
generic computation
so another point is complete it's a
problem that is like a puzzle a tiling
where you have some fixed set of tiles
and you're asking whether you can tile a
square of a certain size
by using tiles from this side and the
adjacent tiles must have
borders of the same color
so here your description of the set of
tiles
easily describes the transitions of
pulling machines
and it's a constant size
piece of your input
but again if you try to make this
reduction work with
trisat or max click pencil decomposition
any
problem that
has less structure
it doesn't seem possible to make these
reductions work
um
okay
down
notes i guess we'll
continue tomorrow and i want to show you
a way to map
the distributions that we don't know how
to optimally compress
to
still map them to the uniform
distribution in that case instead of
using compression we will use hashing
so that's where
it's like going from
unsupervised learning where you are kind
of
learning features that compress the data
to using random features as an
and
and then we will
discuss some more the kind of things
that this theory is not able to
[Music]
handle
and
maybe also talk a bit about
[Music]
how
average case complexity
is
talked about in a setting of
cryptography and how you do reductions
there all right so um i can still answer
questions if you're not too hungry
to go to lunch otherwise we'll continue
to run
okay so it looks like we have at least
one question
uh i wanted to ask for clarification on
this um
thing where you would need to assume you
can compute cdfs of the distribution so
it seems like this just to get a sense
of what what distributions this rules
out
like things like uh it feels like things
like stochastic block model or
planted clique or something where
computing the probability of an instance
requires summing over
some very large set of potential hidden
variables like for these all these
latent variable problems this is
this is probably ruled out if you
believe that those problems are
sometimes computationally hard like is
that
is that the right intuition whereas say
if if the input was like a random graph
like a gnp graph
now you probably can compute these
things
yeah i mean for me the most intuitive
example but i guess it's a bit out of
scope would be the output was your
random generator
it's something that you just cannot
compress
literally in particular you cannot
compute these cdfs because it would
allow you to compress it and so also
surrounding generators are
incompressible but it's also
true for a related reason i guess that
the type of problems are describing with
planted solutions
it's difficult to compute the cdf
because
to
get a handle of
what kind of
instances come before in lexiographic
order you will need to know
which kind of
vertices were part of the clique just
like for this random generator you need
to know what is the seed
i think these are
uh highly problematic distributions yeah
when there is some kind of hidden
information
that can uh
i mean i don't know how to can get a
reduction from computing the cdf to uh
so fighting the
hidden solution in general but
intuitively that's the kind of
difficulty
thanks
more questions
all right if there are no more questions
let's thank luca one more time and look
forward to tomorrow's lectures